you know i i touch a comment so i'm
writing my i'm just writing my first
book
and i touch upon this in that this sense
of value
that that that i i've struggled with i
have
you know in britain as a young black kid
weren't any black people on television
there was very few
depictions of black success uh you know
in
in in on on british television so my
as a working class first generation
immigrant
child i was very my expectations of
what i could do were really quite basic
you know i thought it was probably a
factory or assembly line or you know
i didn't i didn't i didn't i didn't even
i didn't think it was possible for me to
be an actor
you know i just had no you know so if
they hadn't suggested it
i certainly wouldn't have tried tried to
do it i just would have thought that
stuff was
off limits to me um and it took me a
while to
settle into that into the profession
into the into the kind of mold
um but but that sense of value and i've
been battling with it for years
years because you know i i
i've had a i've had a america's given
america has given me
a load of it it's given me a load of
that at that of that
acknowledgement you know homeland come
on in
you know supergirl come on in try to
direct the show let's
direct the show it's even a movie here's
a movie
you know and i've never had any of that
in england
never had any of it so it was sort of
it's my sense of value i think i found
my sense of value
uh in america so it's gonna be
interesting to go back to england
which has really not given me very much
um to to see if i can maintain this
sense of self-worth because uh it's a
it's it's a battle in england it's about
do you feel like there's more racism
there did you feel like growing up that
it was just like you could just feel it
you felt like you know
they're looking at me differently there
did you feel it there
well i mean you know this is an
interesting conversation to
be having with an american because you
know i mean american
it's it's an it's an admitted fact in
america racism isn't the biggest fact in
america
yeah you talk about openly talked about
it's a fact of life you deal with it
whereas in england
there was a report literally just
released this morning
which apparently says institutional
racism doesn't exist
racism it doesn't exist uh uh
britain is a beacon of diversity around
the world
and we should look for other reasons as
to why
a disproportionate number of people of
color are still at the
bottom end of the socio-economic ladder
i mean
it's the ultimate gaslighting that
britain is
is is involved with right now to say
that you know besides this whole thing
with
not that i'm a royalist at all something
with megan and harry and all this stuff
you know the the following day after
that interview when oprah's interview
went out
the hot britain was shaking us
racist we're not racist it's your fault
how dare you say we're racist in england
to
accuse somebody of racism to to point
out racism in england
is to accuse somebody of being is to
leave yourself open
to accusations and accusations of being
called the racist so you can't even have
the discussion in britain
because it's denied it's ignored it's
it's disparaged uh so i can't even have
that conversation
so all this you know it's it's a it's a
very peculiar
mindset that that that
we find ourselves in in britain and it's
so so
it's it's that that ties into my
and i'm not surprised as to why so many
you know did a documentary a couple
years ago about mental health and
you know black britons are 10 times more
likely to suffer from
mental health conditions four times more
likely to be sectioned
under the mental health act and it's no
surprise because
you're look you've been gasoline the
whole the whole time
you